at cambodia's Prime Minister says he
will resign and hand over power to his
son Hun Sen says he will step down in
three weeks after claiming a landslide
victory in Sunday's election which the
opposition has called a sham the 70 year
old has been in power for nearly four
decades and he is Asia's longest serving
leader his eldest son 45 year old hoon
menet is a military General Who
currently heads cambodia's Army
well mussoka is a vice president of the
Cambodian National rescue party and
previously served as a member of
Parliament and minister of women's
Affairs she joins us from Providence in
the U.S state of Rhode Island can I just
first start by asking you your reaction
to this announcement that power is now
going to be passed to the sun in the
family
Paul I would like to say that the people
of Cambodia have not spoken on July 23rd
last Sunday the people Cambodia were
denied the right to choose the party of
their choice
which is the Cambodian National rescue
party and the other opposition party the
candlelight party
have no mandate whatsoever to represent
the people of Cambodia if Hansen wants
to transfer his power to his son do it
within his own family within his own
home not for the people of Cambodia to
approve nor for the International
Community to approve and to go along
with this crisis and not the political
crisis in Cambodia where Cambodia has so
many crises social crisis political
crisis and economic crisis let's put
that on the agenda rather than thinking
about an election that was shamed and
now talking about a transfer of power
toward moving toward a dynasty of the
whole family what power does the
opposition have at this stage any any
power at all
I think so otherwise Mr consent would
not have held this sham election in last
Sunday the power that the people of
Cambodia have the power of that the
opposition party have passed is the the
spirit of
um of does the search the hunger for
justice for freedom for a country that
is not that is ruled by law and not
ruled by one man or by one family we
have the power to from inside and from
outside to hold our base together to
hold the people of Cambodia together and
that is why Mr Hansen is so afraid and
wants to move forward even to kill the
people even to put the people in in jail
or to go after the youth that's what he
wants and because he cannot face up to
the power of the opposition and in in
spiritual
and in moral terms spiritually but in
the sense that but you know we look at
this from the outside and obviously
anybody listening to you would say well
in Practical terms he is he is resisting
uh and he because he's in power and now
his son is going to be in power and he's
the longest serving leader in Asia so in
Practical terms the opposition hasn't
been able to stop that
is there in your view is the opposition
anything that can be done
yes
very much so
the Cambodian crisis in the in the 80s
and and Cambodia shook him out of the
Judo side years that took over that
killed over
um a quarter of a million of the people
in Cambodia the on conflict came uh were
seized after the International Community
came with the people of Cambodia and
pulled the factions and to sit together
to end this the conflict to have a peace
talk so the International Community the
signatories of the Paris Pizza Corps the
18 signatories have to come together
again the International Community cannot
just keep on putting out statement the
obligations in the Paris Pizza Corps is
a treaty for peace that is something
that is a a document that whole can hold
the the uh that get bring the people
often Cambodia the International
Community together to face to solve the
crisis in Cambodia
all right musakua thank you very much
for joining us on the program today
thank you